>> EAU, WELCOME WELCOME WELCOME
AND TO FINISH OFF THE
SEASON ON SUCH A HIGH NOTE.
I CAN ONLY SPEAK AS SOMEBODY --
I DON'T KNOW IF RITTER CAN DO
THAT.
I'M PUMPED.
THEY GAVE US AN EXTRA WE OF
THE NFL SEASON.
LIKE THIS WEEK DIDN'T EXIST TWO
YEARS AGO.
SURE, THERE ARE SOME GAMES YOU
PROBABLY SHOULD NOT BEEN ON.
BUT THERE IS MONEY TO BE MADE
TOO.
IT'S AN EXTRA WEEK TO MAKE MONE
SO I'M IN A GREAT MOOD.
>> DEFINITELY TIME FOR MONEY TO
BE MADE TODAY.
YOU CAN GO MAKE SOME MONEY.
I'LL TRY TO HELP YOU WIN SOME
MONEY.
IT'S ACTUALLY TIME TO BUILD THI
PARLAY.
BUT BEFORE WE BUILD THIS PARLAY
I'VE GOT THE WELCOME YOU GUYS T
THE SHOW, BECAUSE I WANT YOU
GUYS TO KNOW WHO IS NEXT TO ME.
YOU GOT A NEW FACE NEXT TO ME.
HIS NAME IS MICHAEL RITTER.
I CALL HIM RIT DOGS.
NEXT TO HIM IS PRODUCER RYAN.
>> ALSO KNOWN AS A MAN OF THE
PEOPLE.
I GO BY TWO NAMES.
>> THE YOU GO, SHAKE YOUR HEAD.
>> DON'T AGREE WITH HIM PICKING
THE PEOPLE HAVE TO DECIDE IF YO
ARE A MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
RYAN IS SITTING HERE TRYING TO
MAKE HIMSELF THE MAN OF THE
PEOPLE.
BUT WE ARE GIVING OUT OUR BEST
BETS.
DROP YOUR LOCKS IN THE CHAT.
WE WILL GRADE YOUR PICKS AT THE
END OF THE SHOW AND RIGHT NOW W
NEED YOUR HELP TO BUILD OUR LAS
REGULAR-SEASON ANYTIME TOUCHDOW
PARLAY.
RYAN, TELL PEOPLE WHAT WE NEED
FROM THEM.
>> WE NEED YOUR GENIUS, WE NEED
YOUR LOCKS.
WE DID EVERYTHING FROM YOU IN
THESE NEXT 30 MINUTES.
BUT RIGHT NOW WHO IS GOING OUT
OF TOWN TODAY?
DROP IT IN THE CHAT.
WE WILL DEBATE IT.
WE WILL PUT IT IN.
IF IT IS MINUS 300 I WILL
PROBABLY LOBBY TAKEN OUT.
BUT WE NEED THREE LAKES.
THAT WILL HAPPEN, I PROMISE.
THREE LAKES AND WE ARE LOOKING
TO WIN, AND WE ARE LOOKING AT
ENDING THE REGULAR SEASON ON A
HIGH NOTE.
SO WHAT I WILL SAY, RADAR, YOU
DID SAY THAT THERE WERE SOME
GAME THAT YOU PROBABLY SHOULDN'
THAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE YOU UP FOR
SOME NOTES EUROS DOWN.
>> SO I'M A BIG NOTE TAKER.
I GOT MY UNIQUE KEYPAD RIGHT
HERE.
THESE UNDERGROUND NEWS -- RULES.
I KNOW I'M NEW, BUT JUST A BIT
OF BACKGROUND:I'M THE GUY THAT
HAS TO SIT HERE AND WATCH THESE
SHOWS EVERY WEEK I MAKE THE
CLIPS AND WE DO ALL THAT BLESSE
ME AND MY BOY BRYCE WAS PROBABL
WATCHING RIGHT NOW.
HANDLE ALL THAT.
SO WE ARE GOING TO SET SOME
GROUND RULES THE CREEK, RIGHT
OFF THE BAT.
THERE ARE FOUR GAMES THAT YOU
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO DROP AN
ANYTIME TOUCHDOWN BIT FROM THES
GAMES.
THESE ARE THOSE GAMES.
BUCKS-FALCON DO NOT DROP A BO
BOX-FOCUS PLAYER.
>> Speaker 3: DO NOT -- AND I
REPEAT -- DO NOT DROP ANYONE
FROM TEXANS OR COLTS IN THE C
CHAT.
NO ONE IS WATCHING THAT GAME
TODAY.
IF YOU HAVE MONEY THAT GAME
TODAY, FIND GOD, COME BACK AFTE
YOU FIND GOD, AND WE'LL TALK.
>>> PANTHERS-SAINTS CHRIS
TAYLOR FROM THAT GAME.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT PAT
PATENTS-SAINT TODAY.
NO CRYSTAL LAWBREAKER CAN'T DO
IT.
>>> AND THE FINAL GAME,
CHARGES-BRONCHIOLES.
SO THOSE ARE THE FOUR GAMES TO
BE ANYONE HAVE ANYTHING ELSE YO
TO DROP INTO THAT'S FINE.
SO DON'T DROP ANY PLAY FROM
THOSE GAMES.
>> KEENAN ALLEN, NO?
OKAY, RITTER BROKE THE GROUND
RULES WE HAVE TO STAND ABIDE BY
GROUND RULES EVERYBODY, PHILIP
THE CHAPPIE I SEE NOW IS HE
HARRIS TO BE I SEE A LOT OF
THINGS.
PLEASE DON'T BE PUSHING
PROPAGANDA BEFORE WE START,
RIGHT, I SEE A LOT OF THINGS
HERE TO BE JORDAN MASON ANY TIM
TOUCHDOWN FOR THOSE WHO DON'T
KNOW SOME PHYSICAL 49ERS SCORED
A TOUCHDOWN LAST WEEK.
I LOVE JORDAN MASON PLEASE THAT
WAS A GOOD PLAY.
NO, NO, A GREAT PLAY, GREG.
>> THAT IS A GREAT PLAY, I'M NO
GOING TO LIE PLEASE I WANT TO
WIN, SO IT IS JALEN HURTS
ANYTIME TOUCHDOWN.
I THINK AND THEN LAWMAKER SAYS
RICHIE JAMES.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY POINTS TH
GIANTS ARE GOING TO SCORE TODAY.
SO RIGHT NOW LET'S TALK ABOUT
JORDAN MASON AND JALEN HURTS.
THERE'S ANOTHER ONE YOU GUYS SE
IN THE MEANTIME, TOSS IT OUT.
I SAW KENNETH WALKER.
>> YEAH, KENTON-WALKER.
>> WHAT'S THE NUMBER ON JALEN
HURTS?
WHAT IS DRAFTKINGS GIVING US ON
JALEN HURTS BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S A GOOD 1 TO TALK ABOUT T
GET US GOING LET'S GET GOING.
>> ALSO BAIL AND LOTS
IS A LOT OF HARD WORK TOO.
>> RECASTS.
>> WE ARE HOT.
JALEN HURTS MINUS ONE OH FIVE.
I DON'T HATE THE VALUE, I JUST
DON'T KNOW IF THE EAGLES RIGHT
BEFORE THE PLAYOFFS ARE -- BE
ARE GOING TO BE RUNNING THEIR
QUARTERBACK AFTER HE CAME BACK
FROM INJURY AGAINST A TEAM THAT
HAS MADE THE WHITE FLAG TODAY
AND SAYS WE DON'T CARE ABOUT
WINNING.
THAT'S THE GIANTS ORGANIZATION,
BY THE WAY.
THAT'S THEM IN A NUTSHELL, WE
DON'T CARE ABOUT WINNING, THAT'
THEM.
>> I HEARD -- ON THE NO FLY LAN
ON JALEN HURTS JUST BECAUSE A
COUPLE THINGS WE JUST WENT OVER.
BUT I DO SEE STEFON DIGGS WE GE
B THOMPSON 88.
ALSO 20 TO STEFON DIGGS.
IT'S A VERY EMOTIONAL GAME THAT
THE BILLS ARE GOING TO BE
PLAYING.
IT'S IN BUFFALO.
>> IF YOU WANT TO START THIS OU
WITH STEFON DIGGS, I THINK THE
BILLS ARE GOING TO SCORE MANY
POINTS TODAY PLEASE I LIKE THIS
A LOT.
I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH WHAT
GREG IS SAYING ABOUT THE
EMOTIONAL SIDE OF THIS AND DIGS
IS KIND OF THE OFFENSIVE LEADER
OF THIS TEAM WHEN IT COMES TO
NOT BEING JOSH ALLEN.
AND, AGAIN, I THINK LIKE SHOULD
PROBABLY STAY AWAY FROM
QUARTERBACKS' TOUCHDOWN;
ESPECIALLY THESE TEAMS THAT ARE
GOING TO THE PLAYOFFS LIKE THEY
DON'T NEED TO PUSH IT WITH JOSH
SCOBEE JOSH ALLEN HAS A ROCKET
LAUNCHER FOR AN ARM.
HE DOES NOT HAVE TO RUN TODAY.
HE SHOULD WIN THIS GAME.
I KNOW PATRIOTS ARE BUYING FOR.
>> UH-OH, SCOOP.
WE GOT TO VERIFY THIS, BUT MY
MAN LOCKS IN THE WATER SAID DIG
IN TOUCHDOWN NEEDED FOR BILLS
RECORD.
HE SAID DIGS' TOUCHDOWN NEEDED
FOR BILLS RECORD THAT'S WHAT WE
CALL A SCOOP, RYAN, THAT'S WHAT
YOU CALL A SCOOP.
>> LOCKS ON THE WATER, LET US
KNOW WHAT BILLS RECORD WILL BE
BROKEN IF DIGGS GETS A TOUC
TOUCHDOWN.
>> HOLD ON ONE SECOND.
BAGELS AND LOX COMPANY BECAUSE
IT'S A PLEASURE SAME GAME SAID,
RYAN THE RAT LET ME GET JAMES
COOK ASAP.
>>> WE JUST SAID NICE THINGS
ABOUT YOU.
I AM GOING TO DISAVOW EVERYTHIN
I SUGGESTED ABOUT LOGAN.
HE IS MY ENEMY NOW.
WELCOME TO THE ENEMY LIST.
>> RYAN THE RAT?
>> LET ME HEAD OVER HERE.
TOM.
>> WE ARE WAITING ON
VERIFICATION.
BUT YOU ARE LOCKING IT IN, RYAN
TEACHES YEAH I THINK WE ARE GOO
WITH THIS LEG.
THIS IS LEG ONE, IN MY OPINION
THIS YOU WANT TO OPEN UP THE
CHAT JUST TO APPROVE?
I THINK EVERYONE IS ON THIS.
>> YEAH.
LET'S DO THUMBS UP IN THE CHAT
IF YOU GUYS LIKE IT.
IN THE MEANTIME, BETWEEN TIME,
RYAN CLARK WILL LOOK AT THAT
JORDAN MASON.
I'M PUTTING MY FOOT DOWN PRETTY
HARD.
>> I KNOW.
I LOVE THE JORDAN MASON PLAY.
JORDAN MASON -- PLEASE LET ME
KEEPS GROWING.
PLUS THREE.
>> THERE HE IS.
WOO-HOO.
>> RYAN, LISTEN TO ME.
MCCAFFREY IS NOT GOING TO PLAY
AS MUCH TODAY.
>> SNOW.
>> NINERS ARE ALREADY THERE.
YOU KNOW, I'M SAYING THEY ARE
TRYING TO SAVE HIS LEGS.
SKY UP, JORDAN MASON -- NEXT GU
UP ON JORDAN MASON THE QUICK
QUESTION, GREG:WHY IS -- IS
COREY CLEMENT -- THOUGH, COREY
CLEMENT IS ON THE CARDINALS, SO
NEVERMIND.
>> HERE WE GO.
UPDATE FROM LOCKS UNDERWATER
RECORD TOUCHDOWNS HELD BY BILL
BROOKS, SO HE WILL BREAK THE
RECEIVER RECORD, I BELIEVE, FOU
TOUCHDOWNS IF HE SCORES.
SO WE LOGIN STEFON DIGGS.
I AM SORRY, RYAN, APOLOGIES.
I HAVE TO LET THE AUDIENCE KNOW
WHAT WE WERE LOCKING IN STEFON
DIGGS, BUT WHAT WAS YOUR
QUESTION?
>>> NO, NO, NO, ALLGOOD, I ENDE
UP IN MY HEAD.
JORDAN MASON, IF WE HAD JORDAN
MASON THIS PARLAY IS UP 778
PEOPLE AND TO BE HONEST, THIS I
ALL I EVER WANT ON THE SHOW, TO
GIVE ME WHAT I WANT IN THE LAST
WEEK.
THIS IS IT.
>> I THINK THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT
YOU WANT, THE BEST WAY WE COULD
POSSIBLY END THIS IS A TWO-LEG
PARLAY THAT GIVES US ALMOST PLU
800 VALUE.
AND IT HAS STEFON DIGGS AND
JORDAN MASON.
LIKE THAT IS THE MOST -- IF YOU
WANT TO BRAND THIS AS A RYAN
PARLAY WHICH WE'VE DONE IN THE
PAST, THIS WILL BE AT RIGHT H
HERE.
>> STOP IT.
TWO THINGS:NO.
AND, SECOND TO WE MAY NOT HAVE
SAM HERE BUT WE HAVE SAM UP.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED WITH
THE PARLAY.
>> IF THERE IS.
>>> IT'S STILL HERE.
>> YEAH.
IT SAYS LOCKING THIS TWO TEAMER
BRO.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> THAT'S NOT HAPPENING.
BUT YOU HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
STANDING YOU AND THAT YOU DON'T
WANT TO GO FOR GREAT IS.
YOU ARE TRYING TO SETTLE HERE
FOR TWO LEGS.
WE PROMISED THE PEOPLE A FEW LE
PARLAY.
AND DRAFTKINGS CONTINUES HE
WANTS US TO CONTINUE PLACING
THIS ONE.
>> WHICH IS A SIGN.
>> GUYS, GUYS, GUYS, GOT ANOTHE
SCOOP.
GOT ANOTHER SCOOP.
JAMAAL WILLIAMS, WANT TO TURN
AWAY FROM SENDER'S EAGLES --
SANDERS' SINGLE-SEASON LINES
RECORD TO BE HE'S A TV VULTURE
GET A TON OF TOUCHES NEAR THE
GOAL LINE.
>> GUYS, I -- I DON'T KNOW.
THE ONLY REASON I SAY THIS IS
BECAUSE THIS GAME COULD
POTENTIALLY MEAN SOMETHING FOR
THE LIONS.
SO LIKE YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
FORCE-FEED SOMEBODY WHEN HE MAY
NEED TO WIN THE GAME.
>> I HEAR THIS WHAT THEY'VE DON
ALL YEAR.
>>> I WAS JUST ABOUT TO SAY T
THAT.
I HEAR YOU.
>>> IT'S IN THEIR GAME PLAN.
>> YEAH, I HAVE ANOTHER TAKE ON
THIS GAME, THOUGH,:TYLER LYONS,
RANDOM TITANS HAVE BEEN SCORING
AT AN INSANE CLIP RECENTLY.
>> YOU INTO TOSSING NINERS PLUS
270?
>>> I'M NOT SAYING I'M AGAINST
IT, BUT, I MEAN, HOW CAN WE --
LIKE THIS IS GOING TO BE THE
GAME OF THE DAY.
>> IT IS PRETTY JAMAAL WILLIAMS
A- 135, WHAT'S THAT DO FOR US?
OH, GOD.
YEAH.
THIS IS -- YEAH.
>> ARE WE JUST LEAVING JORDAN
MASON IN THIS?
IS THIS LIKE A BIT THAT WE ARE
GOING TO -- LIKE WE ARE
COMMITTED TO THE BIT OF JORDAN
MASON?
>>> WHAT'S THE BID?
THIS WAS A LOCK DROP IN THE C
CHAT.
NO.
>> WHO DROPPED THIS IN THE CHAT?
DID YOU DROP IN THE CHAT?
>>> WITH MASON WOOD DROPPED IN
HERE.
I WILL SCROLL BACK INTO IT.
I WILL DO THE DIRTY WORK HERE.
>> I LIKE TO SEE WHAT IT IS.
>> FOR ASKING -- I AM A NINERS
FAN, IGNITER FAN HERE.
I READ UP ON THE NINERS DAILY
GOT INSIDERS ON THE NINERS THAT
ARE MY FRIENDS.
ABOUT IS SAYING THAT MY MAN --
THEY ARE SAYING ANDREW MITCHELL
WAS COMING BACK FOR THE '90s
TODAY SO THAT'S GOOD TO LIMIT
JORDAN MASON TOUCHES.
BUT ELISHA MITCHELL IS ON THE
PITCH COUNT.
HE IS GOING TO HAVE LIKE 5 TO 1
SNAPS, MAYBE 15, SO HE'S NOT
GOING TO SEE A LOT OF TIME HERE
SO, I DON'T KNOW, RYAN; I WAS
GIVING YOU TIME 2, DING, DING
THAT FOR THE FAN THAT MENTIONS
JORDAN MASON, BUT I JUST WANTED
TO GIVE THEIR PERSPECTIVE TO TH
PEOPLE.
ELISHA MITCHELL IS ON THE PITCH
COUNT IS YEAH, IS I'M TAKING
THAT SNAKE BIGELOW LOCKS DROPPE
MITCHELL.
>>> OH, HE DROPPED ELISHA
MITCHELL YEAH 2 MINUTES AGO.
TWO MINUTES AGO I WOULD'VE
CALLED THE KING BUT NOW HE'S A
SNAKE.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE HOW THOSE
THINGS WORK.
>> IT SEEMS LIKE THE CHAT IS
VERY PRO-JAMAAL WILLIAMS AND
VERY WHERE THE HELL THE JORDAN
MASON COME FROM.
CAN WE DO SEE WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE IF WE TAKE OUT OUR GOOD
FRIEND JORDAN MASON?
>>> OKAY.
BUT, AGAIN, RIGHT, IT IS PLUS
236 SO WE NEED A THIRD LEG NO
MATTER WHAT.
>>> AND WE SAID BEFORE THAT'S
WHAT WE ARE GOING TO DO.
>> YES.
>> YEAH.
>> DON'T KNOW, GUYS.
>> JACK HIM IS IN THE -- KINDLE
HAS BEEN IN LOCKSTEP WITH BROCK
PURDY BUT WE MAYBE COULD FIND
SOMETHING BETTER.
>> I DON'T WANT ANYTHING TO DO
WITH THAT NAME.
I KNOW IT WASN'T ONE OF THE
GAMES THAT I LISTED THAT ARE IN
OUR LOCAL LET'S NOT TOUCH THIS,
I DON'T KNOW, I HAVE STAYAWAY
VIBES FROM THAT ONE.
HE ALSO SAID, GREG, THAT THE
GAME MIGHT THAT MEAN TOO MUCH
THE 49ERS AND A CERTAIN POINT,
SO I DON'T KNOW IF I WANT THEM
SOMEBODY WAS LIKE A BONA FIDE
STARTER.
I REALLY DO THINK THE JORDAN
MASON THING -- JORDAN MASON.
>> I AGREE.
I AGREE EASY THIS IS THE MOST
ANYONE HAS EVER TALKED ABOUT
JORDAN MASON, SO WE SHOULD PUT
THIS AND SAY YEAH, LISTEN,
SOMEONE TALKED ABOUT YOU TODAY,
ISN'T THIS COOL?
JORDAN MASON WILL WATCH HOP ON
THIS ONE DAY.
YOU WANT TO MOVE ON?
ANYONE ELSE WANT TO MOVE ON OR
IS IT JUST ME?
>>> TO JORDAN MASON?
TO MOVE PAST JORDAN MASON,
YOU'RE SAYING?
>>> LET'S MOVE PAST JORDAN MA
MASON, THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING T
SAY.
>> LET'S DO IT.
WE NEED ANOTHER BET.
>> THE CHAT ROOM IS DROPPING
LOCKS IN LIKE CRAZY AND TALKING
ABOUT JORDAN IS LIKE HE IS VERY
SANDERS 70.
HE MIGHT BE.
>> HE REALLY MIGHT BE.
>> I SAID YEAH, COME ON.
I REALLY LIKE THAT ONE.
>>> I LIKE IT TOO, RYAN, I LIKE
IT TOO.
NOT EVEN BECAUSE I AM A NINERS
ABOUT BECAUSE OF THE WAY THE
GAME IS GOING TO BE PLAYED TO
TODAY.
>> YOU KNOW IF HE SCORED A
TOUCHDOWN YOU WILL LOOP AROUND
AT ME SOMETIMES I PUT THE
POINTER MOJI.
I AM WILLING TO LET THAT HAPPEN.
TWO THINGS:I DON'T USE THE CLOW
IN MOJI BUT I WILL CLOWN YOU.
THAT WILL HAPPEN.
SECOND, I DON'T WANT TO DO THAT
EVERY ONE OF THE SURE ACT LIKE
WANT TO ACT SAD IN THE EVERY
TIME HE BETS AGAINST THE COWBOY
DON'T LIKE DOING THIS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S NECESSARY.
>> I KEEP SEEING MILES SANDERS,
MILES SANDERS, MILES SANDERS
PHEIC BOSTON SCOTT.
LAST TIME WE SAW BOSTON SCOTT -
HAVE TO GET AWAY FROM THE IDEA
THAT THESE BIG NAMES ARE GOING
TO SCORE TODAY.
MOST OF THEM ARE NOT GOING TO
PLAY.
>> MANQUÉ I'M SORRY, BROTHER.
WHEN I GET THESE GROUPS I JUST
CAN'T HELP MYSELF.
ANOTHER SCOOP, LOCKS UNDERWATER
A.J. BROWN HAS A CAREER GOAL OF
1500 YARDS.
HE NEEDS 99.
'S LINE IS THAT 67.
>> RECOMMEND THIS IS A TOUC
TOUCHDOWN.
>> IT'S A TOUCHDOWN.
>> YEAH HE OH, MY GOD.
HE'S I'M SORRY, THAT'S ON ME.
I'M LOOKING FOR WINNERS.
>> BOSTON SCOTT.
>> IF THERE'S AN INVESTMENT DRO
IN HERE AND I THINK GREG, AS A
BE RAINING AND I AM SURE YOU AR
AVAILABLE, I SAW QUITE A FEW
TIMES IN HERE BASICALLY OFF THE
BAT AND I THINK YOU CAN FOL29,
HE WAS THE LAST ONE THAT JUMPED
IN NIGEL HARRIS.
I WILL BRING NIGEL HARRIS TO TH
TABLE.
>> I DON'T KNOW HE HAD BEEN
STICKY FUR THIS YEAR.
EVERY TIME I WATCH HIM JAYLEN
WARREN LOOKS DELIBERATELY BE
BETTER.
BUT I AM GOING TO TALK ABOUT IT
IF YOU GUYS WANT HOLD ON, I AM
TRYING TO DROP SOME PROPAGANDA
HERE IN THE CHAT.
OKAY, GO FOR.
A LOT OF A.J. BROWN.
I THINK THAT IS BECAUSE WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT HIM BUT I SEE A
LOT OF A JIM BROWN.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> MANQUÉ MANQUÉ YEAH --
>> SOMEBODY JUST DROPS JORDAN
MASON.
>> RYAN, I SEE JORDAN MASON THE
COMMENTS TOO.
>> WE DON'T HAVE TO SAY THE
USERNAME.
>> I DO SEE ANOTHER ONE, ANOTHE
ONE DROPPED DURING MASON.
>> WE LOST CONTROL OF THE PA
PARLAY.
>> NAJEE HARRIS IS MINUS 110 TO
BE LET'S SAY WE WERE TO BOSTON
SCOTT WHICH IS ALSO A LOCK,
BECAUSE IT IS -- [INDISCERNIBLE
CAME IN AND REMINDED ME, ALL OF
US, ACTUALLY, THAT BOSTON SCOTT
ALWAYS SCORES AGAINST THE GIANT
BE THIS IS PLUS 542.
I DON'T HATE IT ALSO THE FACT
THAT NAJEE HARRIS IS IN THIS
PARLAY THAT IS THE ONLY THING I
HATE ABOUT IT PLEASE I'M SORRY.
NO, NO, NO, GREG, THIS IS ONE O
THE RARE TIMES O TRACE SALON
HERE ANOTHER JORDAN MASON.
>> MULTILEVEL.
>> STOP TALKING ABOUT JORDAN
MASON TO BE JORDAN MASON, TRASH.
>> THIS ONE SAYS JORDAN MASON
FOR SURE.
>> SQL HERE DOING WHAT I DID,
YOU ARE CHERRY PICKING THE
COMMENTS.
JORDAN MASON TO BE ONE OH TWO
MASON A LOCK.
>> SAPD KYLE SUMMERS THE MADRE
STEVENSON.
GET OUT OF HERE, THAT'S NOT EVE
HAPPENING.
>> SLIM JIM, JORDAN MASON.
YES, SIR.
>>> IT'S A JORDAN MASON DAY.
>> DO WE LOCK IT IN?
>>> HOW DO WE NOT?
I MEAN, THE PEOPLE ARE ALL OVER
JORDAN MASON.
SEE, HERE'S THE THING TO BE
RITTER TRIED TO JUMP IN HERE AN
HE DID AND TO GIVE ALL THESE
BUNCH OF RULES.
HE DOESN'T REALLY TRY GREG,
WHERE THE CAP.
>> HE DOESN'T REALIZE -- WE ARE
MEN OF THE PEOPLE.
SO WHEN WE SAY SOMETHING THE
PEOPLE RESPOND TO IT.
>> RITTER, HE WANTED TO KNOW
WHERE JORDAN MASON CAME FROM,
THIS WASN'T JUST OUT OF THIN A
AIR, GREG AND I DID BEFORE THE
SHOW SAY JORDAN MASON, JORDAN
MASON.
YOU ACCEPTED.
HE WENT THREE LAYERS DEEP.
SOMEBODY PLANTED THIS, AND IT'S
NOT GOING TO BE IN MY HEAD.
NOW I'M GOING TO WAKE UP
TOMORROW MORNING AND BE THINKIN
ABOUT JORDAN MASON HOW IF HE
SCORED A TOUCHDOWN TODAY.
WELL THIS ONE SAID MASON WILL
PLAY IN THE SECOND HALF AND HE
GETS BUSYFACT.
>>> I'VE SEEN IT.
>> AND I WILL SAY THIS, RITTER,
YOU COULD ALSO WAKE UP TOMORROW
THINKING ABOUT MASON AND BE LIK
MEANWHILE, JORDAN MASON IS
ANOTHER REASON WHY I CAN BUY A
PS FIVE TODAY, RIGHT?
I MEAN, THAT IS TRUE.
AND WE HAVE THIS.
THIS IS THE PARLAY I'VE ALWAYS
WANTED FOR THE SHOW.
>> AND THAT'S WHAT I WORRY ABOU
IN THIS UNFOLDS, RYAN MCGINNIS
HE SAW IT FOR PLUS 270 AND WE
ARE GETTING IT FOR A TEAM TO 1
TEAM PARLAY.
EXAM IS NOT HERE.
>> SAM IS IN THE CHAT.
>> SAM IS IN THE CHAPTER I KNOW
BUT THIS IS, I'M A SUBSTITUTE
TEACHER AND YOU ARE JUST DOING
WHATEVER YOU WANT RIGHT NOW
THAT'S WHAT THIS JORDAN MASON
THING IS.
>> THIS WOULD NEVER HAPPEN.
I AM TOO MUCH OF A PUSHOVER AND
I SEE THE 15 TO 1 AND I'M LIKE,
YOU KNOW, IT'S THE DEVIL ON THE
SHOULDER-ANGEL ON THE SHOULDER
LIKE WHY ARE WE DOING THIS?
PLEASE SOMEBODY PUT JORDAN MA
MASON.
>> HEY, WE ARE GOOD ON JAMAAL.
HOLD ON, I AM GOING TO ASK THE
CHAP NOW THUMBS UP IF WE ARE
COOL WITH THIS QUANTUM DOWN IF
WE ARE NOT.
AND IF YOU ARE THUMBS DOWN, TEL
US WHAT YOU DON'T LIKE AND WHO
YOU WOULD PREFER SEEING IN THIS
AND WE WILL TALK ABOUT IT.
I WAS IN THE FIRST TWO LEGS OF
THIS I'M ALL IN.
THERE BEEN NAMES THROWN OUT WIT
THE THIRD LEG.
I AGREE, IF YOU DON'T LIKE
JORDAN MASON WITH A THUMBS DOWN
GIVE US ANOTHER OPTION.
I AM READY FOR SEEING ANNA
JUSTIN JEFFERSON.
>> YEAH.
WHAT DOES JJ LOOK LIKE?
>>> BOY, HERE WE GO.
>> YOU KNOW I LIKE JJ ESPECIALL
IF IT'S MONEY.
>> YOU KNOW I LIKE JJ.
I LOVE JORDAN MASON TOO, RYAN.
I AM RIGHT THERE WITH YOU.
>> MINUS 110.
I'M LIKE I LIKE THE IDEA OF US
CAPPING THIS OFF WITH JAMAAL
WILLIAMS ON SUNDAY NIGHT
FOOTBALL I ALSO REALLY LOVE
STEFON DIGGS.
CAN, YOU KNOW, I WOULD TEND TO
JORDAN MASON'S NAME ON MY
SHOULDER AT THIS POINT.
I DON'T KNOW WHO WE WANT TO TAK
OUT HERE.
MIXED RESULTS BUT THERE IS
DEFINITELY MORE THUMBS DOWN THE
THUMBS UP.
JUST SAYING.
>> IS THERE.
>>> IT'S DEBATABLE JOE DEAN 75
WITH LAUGHING EMOJIS AND
THUMBS-UP MOJI WHICH SOUNDS LIK
HE IS ROOTING FOR US.
>> NO, NO.
>> HAVING A GOOD TIME WITH THE
BOYS.
>> LAUGHING AT THE SHOW,
LAUGHING AT US.
YOU KNOW, LAUGHING AT US
CREATING THIS PARLAY TALKING
ABOUT JORDAN MASON.
THAT'S HOW I'M READING.
>> CAN WE DO SEE WITH THE
JEFFERSON IS WHEN WE TAKE OUT
YOUR BOY JORDAN MASON, WHAT WE
ARE LOOKING AT HERE?
>> A.J. BROWN AND --
>> YEAH.
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW I FEEL ABOU
A JIM BROWN.
PLUS 542.
>> I LIKE AJAY.
I'M NOT GOING TO LIE, I LIKE
THIS.
CAN WE DO LIKE ANOTHER PARLAY
WITH JORDAN MASON, THOUGH?
>>> JORDAN MASON, AND WHO WAS
THE OTHER, BOSTON SCOTT?
LET'S JUST GET GOOD MASON-BOSTO
SCOTT.
>> WE HAD IT, GREG.
WE HAD IT.
>> ALL RIGHT, YOU KNOW WHAT, I
AM BACK ON IT.
JORDAN MASON.
LOOK AT THE COMMENTS.
>> WHAT WHAT ARE THE COMMENTS?
JORDAN -- GREG, I DON'T KNOW IF
THIS IS BECAUSE THERE ARE 3Y
PLAT BUT GREG WITH 3G TOPS IV
IVORY, SO PROBABLY SOMEBODY WAN
TO BE MASON.
>> I THOUGHT I WAS VERIFIED, BU
I GUESS I'M NOT, I GOT TO WORK
ON THAT.
>> BIG UNLOCKS SAID KURT MIGHT
NOT PLAY A HIM.
I FEEL LIKE OF CRITICAL TO PLAY
I WOULD JUST SIMPLY.
ALSO THE OTHER -- I DON'T KNOW,
THEY KIND OF NEED TO WIN.
NO, THEY DON'T, ACTUALLY,
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO TIEBREAKER.
THEY DON'T WIN ANY OF THE
TIEBREAKERS.
>> IT IS DEFINITELY RISKY
BECAUSE THIS IS LIKE A PRESEASO
GAME FOR THEM.
THEY WILL PLAY LIKE THE FIRST
HALF.
>> ALSO, THE BEARS QUARTERBACK
IS NOT JUSTIN FIELDS, WHICH
MEANS WE WILL SEE THE WORST
VERSION OF THE BEARS.
THEY HAVE A CHANCE TO GET A
NUMBER ONE.
TODAY.
I TALKED MYSELF OUT OF JUSTIN
JEFFERSON.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU GUYS FEEL
ABOUT THAT.
HEY, ALL RIGHT, TALK ABOUT NO
JJ.
PUT TRENT MASON BACK IN AND
THAT'S IT ON, MAN.
LOOK AT RITTER.
HE'S ABOUT TO LOSE IT.
HEY, RYAN, BROOKE, YOU TALK
ABOUT RAGE.
THIS IS IT.
>> SINCE THE BEGINNING YOU
TALKED ABOUT GETTING RACHEL ON
THIS SHOW, LIKE ALMOST SINCE YO
BEEN ON THIS SHOW.
EVERY WEEK YOU COME ON YOU TALK
ABOUT GETTING ME, SAM, WE'D ALL
BE LIKE RYAN, WE ARE TRYING TO
WIN, WE ARE TRYING TO WIN, WE
ARE TRYING TO WIN.
TODAY, WEEK 18, THE LAST WEEK O
THE SEASON, RYAN.
LET'S GET RICH.
>>> AGAIN, THIS IS ALL I HAVE
WANTED TO LET'S GET RICH.
LET'S WRITE UP INTO THE SUN AT
SUNSET THAT IS THE NFL PLAYOFFS
ON THE HIGHEST NOTE THAT IS
HUMANLY POSSIBLE.
>> LET'S DO IT.
>> SAID HE WANTS RITTER TO STOP
THEM.
THAT AIN'T GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> I KNOW YOU WERE ALL LIKE IN
THE JEFFERSON LEG TOO.
I HEAR YOU, YOUR VOICE IS NOT I
THE CHAT RIGHT NOW, BUT IT IS
TWO AGAINST ONE BE I HAND UP,
CANNOT ENDORSE THIS.
IT DOES NOT MEAN I WILL NOT LET
IT.
I, OF COURSE, WILL BET IT, BUT
CAN'T GO ALONG WITH THIS RIDER,
JOE DEAN 75 SAYS REEDER, WE NEE
A PUBLIC APOLOGY NEXT WEEK WHEN
JORDAN MASON SCORES.
>>> I'M AFRAID THAT I WILL BE I
THE SHOW NEXT WEEK.
WE WILL HAVE AN ANNOUNCEMENT
ABOUT THAT LATER AND IT WILL GE
A PUBLIC APOLOGY BUT I SEE A LO
OF LET'S GET RICH WE ARE GETTIN
RICH, PHAM.
>> LET'S GET RICH, RYAN.
>> SUBSTITUTE TEACHERS AND YOU
GUYS ARE THIRSTY FOR ROUND THE
CLASSROOM WANT TO SHOW UP AND
YELLING OBSCENITIES, AND YELLIN
JORDAN MASON, AND I CANNOT HELP
THIS.
>> RYAN, SINCE WE STARTED THE
SHOW'S WELCOME WELCOME ABOARD
WILL WELCOME ABOARD.
THIS IS GOING TO BE SO MUCH FUN
WE'LL WORK IT OUT TOGETHER AND
GREG AND I STIFF ARMED YOU.
>>> AND THE CHAT YOU CAN'T SAY
IT WAS JUST THE TWO OF YOU.
>> OH, NO, THE CHAT LOVE JORDAN
MASON.
BY THE WAY, I -- THANK YOU, CHE
CULVER FINALLY COMING IN HERE
AND BEING LIKE LET'S TAKE THIS
TO THE BUILDING.
>> IF YOU WANT TO BE CRAZY,
SOMEBODY DROPPED IN TAKE OUT
JAMAAL WILLIAMS AND PUT IN
BOSTON SCOTT SO IT IS DIGGS
CHRIS CONNER MASON SO IT'S LIKE
33 TO 1 OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
THIS WAS JUST JUMP IN AND SAID
MALEAH DAVIS, JORDAN MASON,
BOSTON SCOTT MALIK DAVIS IS THE
THIRD STRING RUNNING BACK FOR
THE COWBOYS I MADE THAT BUT ON
THE SIDE.
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO GO CHECK
WITH THOSE ODDS ARE.
>> LET'S GET RICH RICH.
>> THIS IS THE WEEK.
IS THE WEEK THAT DOESN'T MAKE
ANY SENSE.
>> YES, THIS IS THE WEEK TO GO
GET RICH.
ABSOLUTELY THE WEEK TO GO GET
WRISCO WEEK 18.
RYAN YETZER.
>>> I THINK YOU'RE LOOKING UP
SOME ODDS BUT --
>> YEAH I WAS TRYING TO DO THE
BACKUP RUNNING BACK PARLAY.
SORRY BUT I WILL STAY FOCUSED.
LET'S WALK THROUGH THIS.
>> LET'S RUN THROUGH IT.
>> LEG ONE STEFON DIGGS, ANYTIM
TOUCHDOWN MINUS 115.
LEG TWO, SUNDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL,
MAYBE GAME OF THE YEAR, JAMAAL
WILLIAMS MINUS 125.
AND, LIKE THIS, SOME ARE CALLIN
IT THE LUCKIEST LEG.
I AM CALLING IT THE CHAT LEG
JORDAN MASON PLUS BE 70.
WHAT ARE THOSE ODDS?
THREE LEGS PLUS 1481.
THIS IS THE WEEK WE CAN GET R
RICH.
GREG, WHAT WEEK IS THIS, THE
WEEK WE GET WHAT?
>>> THIS IS THE WEEK WE GET R
RICH.
>> YES, SIR!
>> LET'S GET RICH.
>> I SAID THAT ALL YOU BUT I
SAID IT WEEK 18 TO LET'S GET
RICH, RITTER!
LET'S GET RICH!
>> PUMP THE CHEST, RITTER, PUMP
THE CHEST!
>> THE YOU WANT TO HIT HIM WITH
THE SILENCER.
>> MY JOB IS ON THE LINE.
I AM GOING TO HEAR ABOUT THIS I
MY ONE-ON-ONE WITH SANDERS.
JORDAN MASON, JORDAN MASON.
>> LET'S GO.
>> THIS IS IT.
>> MAKE SURE YOU GUYS TELL US O
DRAFTKINGS.
AND WOULDN'T DO A SUNDAY IF I
DIDN'T DO A LITTLE ANYTIME
TOUCHDOWN BLUES MAGIC.
SO WE ARE ALSO GOING TO BOOST M
MAN JOE MIXON ANYTIME TOUCHDOWN
FROM MINUS 120 TO PLUS 110.
OKAY, I LIKE THAT.
I LIKE JOE MIXON.
HE'S FROM THE BAY AREA.
JORDAN MASON LAYS IN THE AREA.
THE GAME IS GOING TO TAKE PLACE
IN THE BAY AREA.
I SEE THAT THAT'S NEXT AND BEIN
CONNECTED.
BUT ALSO WE MENTIONED JUSTIN
JEFFERSON EARLIER IN THE SHOW.
JUSTIN JEFFERSON NEEDS 194 YARD
TO BREAK KEVIN JOHNSON
REGULAR-SEASON RECEIVING YARD
RECORD RYAN FOR US TO LOOK AT
DRAFTKINGS AND SEE WHAT IT LOOK
LIKE THE BED ON HIM TO BREAK TH
RECORD.
>> HE NEEDS 194 YARDS LIKE YOU
SAID TO DRAFTKINGS AND ITS
WEEKLY SPECIALS HAS WHAT THEY
CALL THE RECORD BREAKER AND ITS
A+ 650 TODAY.
CLICK ON THAT PLUS 650.
IF YOU LIKE TO ZIZZERSON TODAY
AND IF YOU SAY WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, KIRK
COUSINS IS GOING TO PLAY ALL
FOUR QUARTERS.
THEY ARE GOING TO FEATURE
JEPPESEN BECAUSE THAT'S JUST
WHAT THEY DO.
THIS IS THE BEST FOR YOU.
TO MAKE HISTORY IT'S JUSTIN
JEFFERSON PLUS SIX OF THE ON
DRAFTKINGS.
THIS IS IT, GUYS.
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU GUYS
FEEL ABOUT IT.
THIS IS IT.
>>> I ONLY GET MY TAKE.
>>> I HAD JV LAST WEEK AT MY
FANTASY CHAMPIONSHIP AND HE DID
NOT SHOW UP.
HE SHOULD EASILY HAVE THIS
RECORD EASILY HAVE THIS RECORD.
HE DID NOT SHOW UP.
>> YEAH.
>> BUT TODAY IS A NEW DAY.
THEY ARE PLAYING THE BEARS.
THE BEARS PASS DEFENSE IS MAYBE
IT MIGHT HIT, MAYBE.
>> RITTER, YOU DID THIS WITH
KEVIN JOHNSON WEEK ONE.
I CALL HIM KEL, BUT YOU CALL HI
CALVIN.
>> MM-HMM.
>> AND HE SAID THIS RECORD MIGH
BE BROKEN; AND I CORRECT?
>>> YES, WHEN WE TALK KEVIN
JOHNSON -- AND WE WILL HAVE A
COUPON.
OF JUSTIN JOHNSON BREAKS WE WIL
PLAY BACK.
HE SAID HE LIKED ELSIE BOERSMA
JUST INCHES AND HE SAID HE
THOUGHT CHASE WOULD HAVE A
BETTER CHANCE TO BREAK THIS
BECAUSE HE IS A BETTER
QUARTERBACK TO BE KIRK COUSINS
THE RULING HIM OUT?
BUT, NO, HE WAS VERY -- HE HAS
THIS RECORD AND OBVIOUSLY THERE
IS ANOTHER GAME ADDED TO BE
HERE'S MUCH LIKE WANTING TO SEE
THIS BROKEN.
HE IS VERY MUCH A FAN OF THIS
NEXT GENERATION OF RECEIVERS.
AND I PERSONALLY DON'T THINK
JEFFERSON BREAKS THIS TODAY.
I THINK HIS GAME LAST WEEK
REALLY HURT THE CHANCES OF THIS
IS AN AIRPLANE A FANTASTIC GAME.
I WOULD NOT BET TO SAY BUT IF
YOU ARE VIKINGS FAN, IF YOU ARE
A BIG BANK I JUST DON'T THINK
HE'S GOING TO GET ENOUGH
PLAINTIFF TO BREAK THIS RECORD
TODAY.
AND FOR THAT I AM OUT.
>> NICE LITTLE SHARK TANK.
>> YEAH, LITTLE SHARK TANK.
>> RITTER IS OUT IT'S UP TO
DRAFTKINGS FOR DOING THIS LET'S
MOVE ON TO BEST BETS.
IT IS TIME FOR OUR BEST BETS.
RITTER, HOW ABOUT YOU GO FIRST.
YOU ARE THE SUBSTITUTE TODAY
EVEN THOUGH YOU ARE NOT SUBJECT
TO TO US, YOU ARE HERE EVERYDAY
WITH US.
THE HOTTEST TEAM TO THE LEAGUE
YOU ARE HERE TODAY.
THE AUDIENCE SEES YOUR FACE
TODAY.
SO YOU GO FIRST, JUST KNOW WHAT
YOU ARE UP WITH.
I WENT BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN A
COUPLE GAMES FOR MY BEST BET
TODAY AND I REALLY LIKE THERE'S
TWO GAMES WHERE THERE ARE TEAMS
THAT HAVE ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO
PLAY FOR BUT THEY ARE GOING TO
PLAY EVERYONE THAT THEY NORMALL
DO.
THEY ARE GOING AS A TEAM THAT
HAS TO WIN.
AND FOR ME, I'M GOING TO GO WIT
THE RAMS PLUS SIX IS MY BEST BE
TODAY.
I THINK THAT THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT GAME FOR THE RAMS THE
SENSE THAT I THINK THIS IS JOHN
MCVEIGH'S LAST GAME AS COACH OF
THE LOS ANGELES RAMS.
I THINK HE IS BURNED-OUT.
I THINK HE IS DONE.
I THINK HE IS GOING TO GET A TV
JOB I THINK HE'LL BE SITTING IN
THE BOOTH AT TOM BRADY AND KEVI
BURKART AND THAT'S NEXT BOX
BOOTH.
I THINK HIS PLAYERS REALLY LOVE
PLAYING FOR HIM, AND I THINK TH
THING WOULD BE BETTER FOR THEM
IF THEY COULD UPSET AND ROLLING
THE SEATTLE SEAHAWKS, A TEAM
THAT THEY HATE THEIR MIDDLE
LINEBACKER, BOBBY WAGNER, DID
NOT AND HIS TENURE VERY WELL
WITH THE CEO -- CX ORGANIZATION.
HE WILL BE MOTIVATED TO ALSO I
THINK BAKER MAYFIELD THE
QUARTERBACK IS MOTIVATED TO HE
IS PLAYING FOR A CONTRACT TO BE
IN A TEAM NEXT YEAR.
IT MIGHT NOT BE THE RAMS, IP TH
WASHINGTON COMMANDERS.
I THINK THIS WILL BE A VERY
MOTIVATED TEAM THAT THINK A+ S
SIX.
LAKE SHORE CIENKI WINDUS IN
THEIR WATCHING ONTO PLAYOFFS,
GREAT STORY.
I THINK THIS RAMS TEAM WILL BE
MOTIVATED.
IS THE ONLY TIME I EVER BET ON
THE RAMS MY ENTIRE LIFE IN THE
ST. LOUIS SPORTS FAN.
I THINK THIS LINE IS TOO HIGH
AND I THINK AGAIN DEANNA COULD
WIN BUT I THINK THIS RAMS TEAM
IS GOING TO BE MOTIVATED TO GO
TO SEAHAWKS, SO I'M TAKING RAMS.
>> THERE IS, MY MAN MICHAEL
RITTER WALKING IN THE RAMS.
LOS ANGELES YOU GUYS SEE THE R.
THAT STANDS FOR RAMS PLUS SIX.
RYAN, YOUR NAME PICKING.
>> WHAT THE REPT?
RYAN?
>> THIS IS OUR LOGAN.
HE JUST WAGED WAR.
>> HE DID.
>> THAT'S A MISTAKE.
>> DO YOU HAVE A.
>>> I MEAN, IT'S UNBELIEVABLE I
WILL SAY THIS, BAGELS AND LOX I
BACK AND HE WAS RYAN THE RAT.
THIS IS UNREAL.
THE TWO THINGS TO BE THE JORDAN
MASON-BOSTON SCOTT AND LAKE
THERE'S ANY TIME TEST ON PARLAY
IS PLUS 8360.
THAT IS AGAINST PARLAY OF GET
RICH PARLAYS.
BUT, YES, MY.
I AM OF COINCIDES WITH RITTER'S
A BIT.
I HAVE HEARD NOTHING BUT WHAT
THE LIONS CAN'T SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE SEASON COULD B
THE LIONS CAN'T KEEP UP IN THE
NFC NORTH.
THE LIONS CAN'T WIN MORE THAN
SEVEN GAMES.
THE LIONS CAN'T MAKE THE
PLAYOFFS.
AND THEN IF THE LIONS CAN'T PLA
WELL ON THE ROAD, JARED GOFF
CAN'T PLAY COMPETENT QUARTERBAC
IN THIS LEAGUE.
PEOPLE FORGET THAT DAN CAMPBELL
BEFORE THE SEASON ON HBO SAID
THAT THIS IS THE TEAM THAT CAN,
AND THIS IS THE TEAM THAT WILL.
AND THIS IS A GAME WHERE THE
LIONS JUMP IN AND REMINDS PEOPL
THAT THEY ARE THAT TEAM, AND
THAT FOR THE PEOPLE WHO SAID
THEY CAN'T, YOU KNOW, THEY CAN'
SWEEP THE PACKERS IN THE
REGULAR-SEASON, AARON RODGERS I
THE RELAX, RELAX RELAX, THEY AR
GOING TO RUN THE TABLE IN THE
PACKERS ARE GOING TO SMOKE THEM
ONCE LINICK PEOPLE IN LAMBEAU
FIELD TO BE GIVE ME THE LIONS
PLUS FIVE.
PULLED UP.
GIVE ME SO I WAS FIVE.
IS GOING TO BE SEVEN AND TWO.
THIS, O-LINE IS WAY TOO HIGH.
WAY TOO HIGH.
YES.
IF YOU GAVE ME -- IF THE LINE T
HAVE OKAY, MAYBE I WOULDN'T SAY
THIS AND MAYBE I WOULD DROP
LIONS MONEY LINE BECAUSE THAT'S
HOW GOOD I FEEL ABOUT THEM
WINNING THIS GAME BUT THE
DETROIT LIONS PLUS FIGHT WITH
THE TEAM WITH THE MOST GREAT IN
THE NFL, THE TEAM THAT IS OUT
THE BUS EVERYONE'S PREDICTIONS
BEFORE THE SEASON STARTED, THIS
IS THE LIONS, GUYS.
I'M A DAN CAMPBELL GUY THROUGH
AND THROUGH.
I GOT MY BIG COFFEE HERE.
THIS IS JUST -- I'M FIRED UP
ABOUT IT.
I'M FIRED UP ABOUT IT.
YOU'RE FIRED UP, RYAN, AND I'M
FIRED UP WITH YOU BECAUSE MY
TIME TO PICK.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS, YOU GUYS HAVE
TWO INTERESTING PICS.
BEFORE I CAME INTO THE SHOW I
SAID, GUYS, I'M HAVING TROUBLE
DECIDING BETWEEN TWO PICS IN MY
TWO PICS WERE YOU GUYS PICS.
SO, GUESS WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP THE VIBES GOING AND WE ARE
GOING TO CONNECT THE DOTS.
THIS IS WHAT WE ARE GOING TO DO.
I AM ROCKING WITH THE LOS
ANGELES RAMS PLUS SIX AND THEN,
RYAN, YOU SAID DETROIT LIONS.
YOU LIKE THE MONEY LINE.
BUT YOU DIDN'T TAKE THE MONEY
LINE.
>> NO I DIDN'T.
YOU TOOK PLUS FIVE?
>>> THAT'S RIGHT BEHAVIOR BUT
THAT'S OKAY.
>> OKAY.
>> I'M GOING TO TAKE THE MONEY
LINE.
THAT'S BIG DOG BEHAVIOR.
I'M TAKING THE MONEY LINE.
I THINK THE LIONS CAN GO OUT AN
BEAT THOSE PACKERS AND SWEEP
THEM THIS SEASON.
ALL THE TURMOIL AARON RODGERS
HAS PUT THAT LIONS FANS BASE IN
THESE PAST YEARS, HE'S BEEN IN
THAT.
IS UNIFORM, AS GOING TO TURN
AROUND TODAY.
THAT IS GOING TO TURN AROUND
TODAY.
GIVE ME LIONS MONEY LINE.
GIVE ME RAMS TO I ALSO WANT TO
TOUCH ON THE RAMS TO BE GREATER
YOU TALK WHAT THE MOST SHARKS -
THEY MIGHT NOT BE BACK NEXT Y
YEAR.
TO MAYFIELD IS PLAYING FOR HIS
NFL CAREER TO BE IS GOING TO BE
A LOT OF EMOTIONS TO BE A LOT O
EMOTIONS IN THAT GAME.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A CLOS
ONE SO I LIKE THE PLUS SIX.
PARLAY BOTH OF YOU GUYS GOT BOT
OF YOU GUYS' PICKS AND, RYAN,
WHERE AM I UP WITH THIS ONE?
>> YEAH PLUS 422.
>> I MEAN, THERE IS.
THERE IS SPEAKER AND YOU GUYS
TALK ABOUT GETTING RICH?
WE GET RICH ON THE PARLAY.
>> WE GOT RICH TODAY.
WE ARE GETTING RICH.
BUT WE ARE GETTING RICH.
ALL RIGHT, THOSE ARE OUR PICKS
TO BE WE ALL FEEL GOOD ABOUT IT
SHOULD BE GREAT SOME BEST BETS,
RYAN, JESUS GREAT SOME BEST B
BETS?
I WILL READ THAT OUT AND WE WIL
ALL CELEBRATE IT TOGETHER LET'S
SEE THE PEOPLE LOOKING FOR A LO
OF PEOPLE DROPPING RAT EMOJIS S
I'M TRYING TO GET THROUGH THAT.
IT'S TOUGH.
>> REALLY HATE TO SEE THAT,
DON'T WE?
PLEASE I WANT TO SHOUT OUT DOIN
WE'LL TWO.
WHENEVER I WAS DOING IN MY.
HE SAID IS NOT A MOVIE
ACCEPTANCE SPEECH.
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO GET RIGHT
TO THE .
I APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK, DY
DYLAN, THANKS.
>> MOSHE J SAID PLUS EIGHT --
8360 PARLAY IT WAS BOSTON SCOTT
MALIK DAVIS AND JORDAN MASON.
OKAY, S RECORD JORDAN MASON ANY
TIME TOUCHDOWN.
A PLUTKO RITTE, RIGHT?
>> MEL SAID I WOULD NEVER CALL
RYAN ARE RAT.
THAT IS RUSER RYAN.
TO THANK YOU.
AND HE KNOWS THE BILLS MINUS SI
ARE THE BEST BUT ON THE TABLE.
WE CAN PLAY THE ULTIMATE GAME
HERE.
BILLS PLUS SIX OH I'LL GO LOOK
UP WITH THOSE ODDS ARE YOU GUYS
TELL ME WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
>> YEAH I WOULD SAY I'M GUESSIN
THAT LIONS DROPPED ABOUT THREE
POINTS FROM WHAT IT NORMALLY IS.
>> IS AT EIGHT RIGHT NOW.
>> IS AT EIGHT?
>>> YEAH.
I'LL GO EIGHT MINUS JUST ON THE
FACT THAT THEY ARE FACING BILL
BELICHICK IN THEIR PLAYOFF LIVE
ON THE LINE.
JOSH ALLEN ON THE BILLS LIKE HE
JUST PLAYS CRAZY WHENEVER HE
PLAYS AGAINST BILL BELICHICK.
SO I'LL GIVE IT AN A MINUS RO
ROUND.
PLAY AN ECHO THOSE ODDS ARE
MINUS 166 SO YOU HAVE A BIT MOR
OF A CLEAR VISION.
I GIVE A B PLUS.
I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO GO OUT
AND PLAY SMASH MOUTH FOOTBALL.
IT'S A LOT OF EMOTIONS.
A LOT OF EMOTIONS ARE GOING TO
BE PLAYING FOR.
THEIR TEAM WENT DOWN AND THEY
ARE GOING TO BE PLAYING FOR HIM
SO I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO GO
OUT THERE AND PUT ON A SHOW.
>> RYAN B SAYS IT'S PLUS THREE
AND A HALF.
WELL, SEND MASON IS A PLUS TEN
NOW?
LOVE IT.
>> IS THAT TRUE?
>>> THAT'S GOING TO MAKE US EVE
MORE RICH WE NEED AN UPDATE ON
THOSE ODDS.
OH, MY GOD, IS THAT TRUE?
>>> IS IT TRUE, DID IT GO UP?
>>> NO, NO, STOP LYING IN THE
CHAT.
>> WHOA, WHOA, WHOA GOT BAD
SCOOPS.
>> OKAY, AGAIN, BRIAN ROCAP JUS
PLUS THREE AND A HALF TO WHAT D
YOU GUYS THINK.
>> I'D SAY NO.
I WAS GOING TO -- I WAS GOING T
BET THE DOLPHINS.
I DON'T KNOW IF TEDDY
BRIDGEWATER IS PLAYING.
THEY SAID TELL YOU MIGHT NOT
PLAY.
THEY SAID HE GOING TO BACK UP -
I THINK IT'S MURPHY WAS A
QUARTERBACK ON THE THIRD STRING
QUARTERBACK PATRIOTS, THOMPSON.
>> IS CONNIE THOMPSON, YEAH.
IS WATER GOING TO BACK HIM UP S
THAT SCARED ME FROM BETTING THE
DOLPHINS.
NOW THE JETS?
PLUS TEN?
I DON'T KNOW, GIVE IT A B.
>> I HAVE NO READ ON THAT GAME
WHATSOEVER AS A SUBSTITUTE
TEACHER YOU WILL GET A NICE C
PLUS.
>> I LIKE THE FACT THEY ARE
GETTING MORE SKYLAR THOMPSON IS
A BONA FIDE BAD QUARTERBACK.
YOU HEARD IT HERE FIRST.
I KNOW THAT'S A HOT TAKE BUT
SKYLAR THOMPSON IS BAD.
AND THE DOLPHINS HAVE BEEN
HORRIBLE RECENTLY, SO I LIKE
THAT.
I ARGUE THAT WHEN A B PLUS TO
DOING WIN GUY USE TURNER, TYLER
TO SPEAK MONEY LINE, AND A
PITTSBURGHER -- PITTSBURGH RI
RIGHT?
I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT GOES TO B
AS A PITTSBURGHER I NEED YOUR
GUYS TAKE.
>> DYLAN, THIS IS DREJKA WE ARE
HAVING EXTRA REPORT BECAUSE I
WAS GOING TO CALL YORK TOO SINC
YOU MAYBE LAUGH PIECES I WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE TWO-YEAR LIKE
SINCE I LIKE THE TEAM PLAYING
FOR NOTHING, I KIND OF LIKE THE
BROWN TODAY, JUST TO THE FACT
THAT THE TEAM STARTED TO PLAY
BETTER THE PAST COUPLE WEEKS.
THEY WOULD LOVE NOTHING MORE
THAN TO RUIN THE PITTSBURGH.
THAT IS ONE OF THE MOST
UNDERRATED BEST RIVALRIES IN
FOOTBALL THEY WOULD LOVE NOTHIN
MORE THAN TO RUIN THE STEELERS
SEASON AND BE THE FIRST TEAM TO
GIVE MIKE TOMLIN A LOSING RE
RECORD, A GUY THAT HAS HAUNTED
THEM FOR A DECADE PLUS.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE REALLY A
GOOD MOTIVATOR FOR THEM GOING
INTO NEXT SEASON BECAUSE I THIN
THAT TEAM IS GOING TO BE GOOD
NEXT YEAR.
THEY HAVE ALL THE PIECES PLAYIN
AND EVERYTHING.
ABOUT THE REASON WHY I DIDN'T G
WITH IT IS MIKE TOMLIN.
HE'S THE BEST COACH IN THE NFL.
I THINK HE WILL HAVE A TEAM
READY TO GO AND I THINK THE
STEELERS NEED A FEW THINGS TO G
THEIR WAY TODAY.
I ENDED UP NOT TAKING IT BUT I
THINK I WOULD LEAN BROWNS OVER
THE STEELERS, AND COMMON IS THE
MAIN FACTOR.
>> LIKE THAT, RITTER IT IS TIME
TO GO MAKE SOME MONEY.
I GOT TO GET TO THE CASINO.
I'M PRETTY SURE YOU GOT TO PUT
YOUR BETS IN.
PEOPLE, YOU GUYS WANT TO YOU GO
TO EITHER GET TO THE CASINO OR
PUT YOUR BETS AND SO IT IS TIME
TO GET ON OUT OF HERE.
VERONICA LET'S REVIEW THE PICKS
TO THIS BEFORE WE SAY GOODBYE T
THE PEOPLE.
>> YES, SIR.
ALL RIGHT, ARGAY WHICH PARLAY I
STEFON DIGGS ANYTIME TOUCHDOWN
MINUS 115, JAMAAL WILLIAMS ON
SUNDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL MATON
FOOTBALL MINUS 125 AND OUR GUY
AND OF THE SHOW JORDAN MASON,
FRIEND OF THE SCHONAU PLUS 270
THOSE ODDS ARE PLUS 1481.
>> GET RICH.
YOU ARE RICH.
>> AND ARE DRAFTKINGS CRAGGS
MAGIC ANY TIME BOOST HIS JORDAN
MASON IS A PLUS 110.
LOVE THAT.
JOE MIXON, NOT JORDAN MASON BE
IT WE ARE GIVING BOTH WERE
JORDAN MASON IT WILL BE PLUS 11
JORDAN MASON SO IN MY HEAD.
JOE MIXON.
I CAN'T STOP THINKING ABOUT JOE
MIXON.
JOE MIXON PLUS 110.
THAT'S OUR ANYTIME BOOST SPEED
AND OUR BEST THAT'S GREGUS
COMBINING OUR TWO, TAKING THE
RAMS PLUS SIX, AND HE LOVES THE
LINES' MONEY ON BECAUSE HE'S A
SMART MAN AND THAT IS A PLUS TW
PEOPLE THAT IS THE PARLAY.
RITTER IS ALL OVER THE RAMS AT
PLUS SIX.
WE ARE REALLY PUTTING THE RAT
TWICE IN THE SHOW THAT'S A
INTERESTING TAKE TO DO THAT.
BUT MY BEST BET AGAINST SIX AND
TWO.
DETROIT LIONS PLUS FIVE.
I LOVE THE LIGHT TO THE ON
SUNDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL.
I THINK YOU WILL BE A CLOSE G
GAME.
THAT IS OUR BEST FOR WEEK 18.
>> THAT'S THE BEST, MAN NEXT
WEEK WE ARE LIVE ON SATURDAY AT
4:00 P.M. EASTERN TO BUILD A
PARLAY AND WATCH THE FIRST GAME
OF WILDCARD WEEKEND.
CHAMPION.
UNTIL THEN MY EYES ARE WATERING.
I GOT TO GET UP OUT OF HERE, M
MAN.
PIECE.
[♪ MUSIC ♪]